our chief engineers Network again my my
chief technology officer greg Haislip
here today part of the process that we
go through are those independent checks
I think you're referencing also some of
the reports in the news about what's
called delegated authority this is how
we extend deep certification processes
into our factories and into our quality
checks and boeing does have a
responsibility there was delegated
authority individuals on our team again
they have an independent assessment
process that we cross-check on a regular
basis and I'm comfortable that that is
solid that is a way for the FAA to
leverage the deep technical expertise of
our team while maintaining the
independent review that's required and
again as our ongoing assessment of our
certification processes will be taken
another look at that to make sure the
right degree of Independence is
available I feel confident that it is
today but our culture is to always look
for opportunities to improve so we will
examine that thank you yeah please we
will take your question sir that will be
our final question
so we'd ask that everybody turn in the
ballots the polls will close at that
time thank you my name is Chris Lawrence
I've been a shareholder for 20 years and
I'm also a private pilot but I've never
had the capital to be a direct Boeing
customer but I got an email a couple
months ago that indicated I was Boeing
acquired for flight yes which is a an
electronic flight book provider that
that really grabbed hold in the part 91
world so I'm curious as a pilot what
sorts of things are you looking to do in
the services industry with respect to
part 91 operators independent of perhaps
Jepsen or some of the other you know 121
135 operations you rate you raise a
great question so it's part of growing
our services business as I talked about
earlier it's one of our biggest growth
opportunities and we see opportunities
to leverage across the business aviation
general aviation community where we did
not have a strong presence today and our
larger airplane community where we
clearly have strength of presence and
that recent acquisition of for flight
that your reference brings together for
flight in Jefferson we're the two
leading companies in those sectors
combines their capability
and will offer us the opportunity to
create new solutions for those customers
so improvements on flight planning and
navigation capabilities you can think of
a range of digital services that will
enhance operations for our pilots at all
levels and by bringing the combination
of Jefferson and for flight to the table
we're going to be able to add value for
our customers across all of those
segments that you reference part 91
included because we we really like that
that is one of the reasons that we've
we've purchased for flight and we think
we can add value to the segments that
both for flight and Jefferson's serve
today all of those segments and you're
right that's an area where again I think
there are opportunities for safety
enhancement or new safety tools that we
can provide as part of our digital
services good question thank you that
concludes our question and answer period
the polls are now closed if you have
additional questions please write them
down on the common cards provided in
your program and hand them to attend an
attendant a Boeing representative will
respond following today's meeting I can
now report the preliminary revolting
results with respect to item 1 the 13
nominees for election to the board
received an average of 98% of the votes
cast in favor of their election with
each director receiving a majority of
the votes cast in favor of election on
item 2 92% of the votes were in favor of
the advisory vote on executive
compensation item 3 96% of the votes
were in favor of the appointment of
Deloitte and Touche
ll P as independent auditor item 4 32
percent of the votes were in favor of
the proposal seeking an additional
report on lobbying activities item 5 7
percent of the votes were in favor of
the proposal relating to the impact of
share repurchases on performance metrics
item 6 34 percent of the votes were in
favor of the proposal seeking an
independent board and chairmen item 7 24
percent of the votes were in favor of
the proposal seeking to remove the size
limit on proxy access groups item 8 25
percent of the votes were in favor of
the proposal relating to mandatory rich
tension of significant stock by
executives all right thank you grant on
the basis of these preliminary results I
declare that each of the 13 director
nominees has been duly elected and that
shareholders have voted to approve the
Advisory vote on executive compensation
and the appointment of Deloitte and
Touche as independent auditor finally I
declare that shareholders have voted not
to approve any of the shareholder
proposals the final voting results will
be available on Form 8-k filed with the
Securities and Exchange Commission I
want to thank you very much for
attending our 2019 Annual Meeting which
is now adjourned thank you
[Applause]